when it comes to your fabric are you  more of a iron type of guy or a steamer  if you had a choice between replacing  your nose with two things which one  would it be in the choices are an anus  or penis  and why in the uh traditional spectrum  of a roy g biv rainbow which one's your  favorite color all colors man you like  orange what's your favorite brand of  lotion uh someone comes out of nowhere  and attacks you like this  okay what do you do  what's your favorite tree oak are you  like oh why do you like oh uh can you  describe what  oaks like and compare it to another tree  uh  if you were blind and you stuck your  hand in a bucket and the bucket was  filled between soil or wet coffee  grounds would you be able to tell  differently  i see subscribers dipping away